c'est toujours la forme qui fait passer
le fond et jamais l'inverse c'est à la
fois le meeting de quelqu'un qui est qui
part gagnant mais qui n'est pas sûr de
gagner
nous sommes là pour faire advenir un
projet de progrès
oui mes amis
tout cela
étant de choses c'était notre projet et
c'est maintenant notre bilan
il s'est entraîné à avoir un public
circulaire c'est au moment de la crise
des gilets jaunes quand il a ensuite
fait ses réunions populaires qu'il a
commencé à comprendre que d'être plus
près des gens c'est-à-dire d'avoir un
public circulaire de pouvoir s'adresser
à gauche à droite en avant en arrière ça
avait un côté plus proche à ce moment-là
du public et je pense qu'il a repris ça
pour sa campagne évidemment la
musicalité va être essentiel pour
attirer un public on peut le résumer
avec un seul mot c'est le mot prosody la
prosodie pour faire simple c'est
l'ensemble des intonations et des
rythmes propres à une langue et chacun a
sa façon de parler sa rythmicité
mélodique propre chez Emmanuel Macron
n'oublions pas que c'est quelqu'un qui
est déjà rompu à l'exercice oratoire
c'est à dire qu'il y a un prix à
s'exprimer nous le ferons
car la France est une nation solidaire
une nation humaine une nation qui ne
laisse personne au bord du chemin mes
amis mes amis
le travail au service du progrès voilà
ce qui nous tient voilà ce qui nous fait
nation c'est pourquoi oui c'est par le
travail par la production que durant ces
cinq années qui viennent nous pourrons
augmenter notre croissance crée plus de
richesses et pouvoir continuer le
progrès je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
a des notions musicales qui a l'habitude
d'utiliser des rythmes et des mélodies
variés
[Musique]
donc à partir du moment où vous savez
varier la rythmicité mélodique vous avez
déjà une attractivité qui est accrue et
vous pouvez utiliser tout un tas de
courbes mélodiques et de rythmes
différents la difficulté c'est de donner
de la voix c'est-à-dire d'avoir une
intensité vocale relativement importante
pendant une durée assez longue il faut
vraiment un entraînement sur notamment
le débit expiratoire c'est-à-dire l'air
que vous allez expulser pour faire
vibrer les cordes vocales il faut que
cette pression d'air soit maîtrisée à
partir du moment où vous montez à l'aigu
vos cordes vocales s'étirent la France
est un bloc
c'est de temps étant d'affluents
[Musique]
nous nous sommes habitués à ce que
l'extrême droite se réclame de Charles
de Gaulle alors que tout dans son
histoire son parcours l'éloigne du
gaullisme alors que même elle est
précisément
l'extrême droite l'héritière de ceux qui
ont combattu le général
j'ai tout de même remarqué que Emmanuel
Macron un certain moment était limite
c'est-à-dire qu'il a failli retomber
dans les travers de son meeting à la
Porte de Versailles le fameux c'est
notre projet et ça encore une fois c'est
parce que la voix monte à l'aigüe sans
être contrôlée le point technique qu'il
faut prendre en compte dans ces cas-là
c'est de démarrer avec une voix plus
grave que d'habitude mais soyons lucides
là aussi
soyons lucides là aussi c'est que nos
valeurs sont les meilleurs réponses au
défi des temps elles sont profondément
modernes
et c'est ce qui va permettre puisque
vous allez monter à l'aiguille lorsque
vous allez donner de l'intensité bien ça
va vous permettre de monter moins haut
c'est bien
je sais bien ce qu'on nous dit
[Applaudissements]
on est obligé de laisser faire la foule
empêcher la foule de montrer ses
émotions c'est un peu compliqué on se
rappelle de d'Edouard Balladur qui avait
dit je vous demande de vous arrêter ça
me paraît très délicat et très difficile
de faire ça aujourd'hui ce qui serait
intéressant d'ajouter c'est qu'on peut
remarquer des différences notoires quant
à l'attractivité des candidats il y a
évidemment une question de fond mais la
forme y est aussi pour beaucoup il faut
bien savoir que c'est toujours la forme
qui fait passer le fond et jamais
l'inverse ça c'est très important de le
noter c'est à la fois le meeting de
quelqu'un qui est qui part gagnant mais
qui n'est pas sûr de gagner il émet
encore il a encore quelques réserves ça
s'entend aussi dans sa voix on se
souvient de Jospin qui partait gagnante
tout le monde le disait gagnant et
finalement il a été battu Emmanuel
Macron a retenu cette leçon
[Musique]